the first feature-length documentary
from cbsn originals looks at deeply
rooted racism
in a progressive southern city welcome
to pine lake is what it's called it
examines how the leadership of pine lake
that's in georgia
america's only city run entirely by
women
allegedly turns a blind eye to
institutional racism
that it did not create but nonetheless
upholds
police chief that sarai yuhada green was
hired as a first black woman on pine
lakes police force back in 1999
after protest over predatory ticketing
of an african-american residence from
the surrounding communities
so in this preview of the movie film
mostly before the pandemic keep that in
mind
chief green explains to mayor melanie
hammett why she wants to serve
here's a look you know you know where
everybody lives you know you actually
engage
you're not necessarily jumping from call
to call to call
so when you're not when you're not
jumping from
call the call it allows you to do the
kitten in the tree crossing the old lady
across the street
it allows you to do those type of things
what's today blue day you got the blue
hat they got the blue shirts
and you got the blue steel work so
nobody sent me a memo
i didn't get the memo
what's your name man chief green she
bring
yes sir yeah what you want to eat this
morning
oh i'm good man i buy you some breakfast
i'm on a diet
my car is giving me hell if you got a
tire issue
mr collins gonna hook you up each person
that has made the life
decision to put on this uniform has a
love for humanity
a desire to serve protect
and be a part of something greater than
themselves
i remembered that as a poem it felt to
me like a poem
did you send it to me because it was
your way of also saying
to the new mayor i want you to see us
this is who you have and you're employed
this this is who we are and i i wanted
it to be a certain
certain level of comfortability too
chief
yehuda green it's an honor and pleasure
to continue
working with you and thank you for
agreeing to do this i'm definitely
humbled
i thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to even open up
and show that other side yeah chief
green's working really hard you know
pine lake they say it's predominantly
white but the surrounding area is 90
black right and so the the complaint was
90
of the complaints were about police
profiling the black community
who were not residents but they were
getting the majority of the tickets yeah
the overwhelming majority of tickets
were going to
people of color yeah and zachary's
saying to that young man we're gonna get
your tire fixed
that's a really key thing because when
you have predatory ticketing
every little thing on your car becomes a
fine if you don't pay the plane it rolls
into something else you can lose your
license
big problems result yep major issue
filmmaker says the council is blind to
institutional racism and excuses it away
they're not tackling it
clearly they want to do something about
that you can watch the cbsn originals
documentary welcome to pine lake this
sunday night at 8 7 central
on cbs